en un momento de altísima convulsión
social colombia superó los 80 mil
fallecidos por kobe 19 tras reportar 490
muertes este viernes el país atraviesa
la tercera ola la más mortal desde el
inicio de la pandemia en el último mes
se reportaron casi medio millón de casos
y más de 13 mil decesos las unidades de
cuidados intensivos siguen al borde del
colapso en bogotá están al 94 por ciento
de ocupación mientras que en medellín y
cali alcanzan el 99 y el 95 por ciento
respectivamente
ellas se están viendo algunas personas
que están falleciendo sin recibir la
atención en una unidad de comida
intensivo
estando en los servicios de urgencias no
pudiendo recibir la atención de un
equipo especializado y tampoco el core x
se conectará un ventilador mecánico que
también es indispensable para este tipo
de situaciones en la etapa aguda
precisamente la alcaldesa de bogotá
claudia lópez anunció que dio positivo
para el virus
los médicos me han informado que tengo
una prueba psd positiva y aunque todos
mis signos vitales están afortunadamente
bien solo tengo un poquito de malestar y
mucho cansancio el 8 de la población
recibió el fármaco contra el commit 19
pero sólo el 5% está completamente
vacunado en un país de casi 50 millones
de habitantes las restricciones para
frenar los contagios divergen en cada
departamento sin embargo las
aglomeraciones son inevitables en pleno
paro nacional pero de hecho la inmensa
mayoría de personas manifiesta con
tapabocas y entre los reclamos de los
manifestantes destaca la retirada de la
reforma de la salud y el acceso
universal a una asistencia sanitaria de
calidad